there are very few things that get me
going more than mock drafts
the draft order ain't even set but we
mock drafting out this mug
okay uh the folks at bleacher report i
want you to just kind of tell me what
you think right
uh take-a-thon gave him the order uh
brett cebleski from bleach report
it's the top ten okay uh
i like top two but you know i like penne
sue a lot of oregon
that's what the bengals need to protect
joe burrow cowboys are gonna be
interesting to see if somebody
decides to you know trade up for a
quarterback
jamar philly is so excited no i'm
getting there
jamar chase to philly is so exciting
because that's exactly what the doctor
ordered
but yeah that's your man zach wilson
maybe get a chance to learn from teddy
bridgewater they don't have to rush him
along
and if alex smith could hold it down a
little while longer same thing for the
football team getting trey lance
to kind of sit there and develop michael
parsons will be a defensive player of
the year one day
but i'm gonna focus on the lions and the
falcons in a second
but i love it man justin fields
jacksonville they're right on the cusp
and they got some other picks i mean
because i won't go through the whole
first round they got but like
the jets if they get lawrence and then
come back and say get a rashad bateman
that'd be fantastic but the one out the
couple of teams i just want to touch on
real quick man
was like just kind of going into
franchise mode for a second if we could
like if you're the lions and the falcons
all right with old friends
matthew stafford and matt ryan
do you get a quarterback if one is is
there in that range
you know if you if there's a a zack
wilson or trey lance or a mac jones even
or
or a kyle trask if any of those dudes
are
you know do you maybe think about
getting a quarterback before you really
need one you know what i'm saying like
you don't want to be needing one heaven
to go out and get it you want to get it
before you really need one
listen like the guy that you know you
and chris sims and others just
insist is like the best quarterback
you've ever seen
aaron rodgers how long did he wait three
years four years
something like that before he i think he
started in his fourth season
so you sit there behind brett favre
and uh and it didn't hurt him i would
say probably helped him more than it
hurt him
sitting there and watching look at
patrick mahomes he waited a year
maybe he should have but he waited a
year behind alex smith
i mean it's been done before when you
take the quarterback
i mean that's the river drew brees
yeah yeah i i think uh i think if you
see a guy
who's good enough you should take him
but i just want to i just want to point
out to you
point that off what you said you said
okay now if you're behind
a matt ryan or matthew stafford near
rookie quarterback yeah you probably
have to wait
but zack wilson being behind teddy
bridgewater
teddy bridgewater even think about being
better
than zach wilson he should if he even
dreams about it he should wake up and
apologize
robin harris uh now come on come on
exactly
teddy bridge look if he beats him teddy
bridgewater is playing good football and
teddy bridgewater is a quality
quarterback
you gotta take the three solid he's a
quality quarterback okay and so it's
nothing you don't have to
it just it just alleviates the need to
have to rush
that's the new quarterback in i decided
i'm just feeling this dude it's
something about
i know and it's hard it's hard to really
evaluate him because
you look at he plays at byu and you know
look at the competition
it's gonna really be difficult for them
i don't think they'll be able to get
into
uh any kind of like major big money bowl
games
but but let's point out byu byu
has had some pretty good quarterbacks in
the past
uh including your including your
favorite
yeah no it's been a while but yeah i
know they have a tradition there for
sure
the one um the one that i didn't uh
mention because it wasn't in the top ten
but just i just i just love this kind of
stuff i saw mike draft i'm like yes sign
me up
i just i like you know i can't get
enough for the draft so why not start
now
and the order ain't even set but uh at
11
on this mock draft which we uh we didn't
uh we didn't show you
the uh the dolphins they had them taking
kyle pitts
i'm like oh that's a sexy pick right
there i mean
that's you want to set two up get him
get him kyle pitts
man that kid and that's oh my god now
who i have not a titan out of florida oh
my god i mean i i i
i hate to call them a tight end you know
i wish they hit i wish it just could
you know some people just you know when
they recruit them they call them
athletes i wish they could have a freak
position
because that's all he really is i mean
it's just unfair to call him a tight end
like i mean the dude
is the truth um
right uh the number 11 yes that's from
the texas
correct oh nicely done michael
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you